les concessions faites été reprise
hésitante sncf perturbations demain
enseignement les négociations sont mal
partis le conseil national palestinien
confirme son virage
yasser arafat sur le point d'imposer une
forme implicite de reconnaissance de
l'état d'israël
le plan anti sida en péril un
préservatif sur trois ne serait pas
efficace selon la revue 50 millions de
consommateurs littérature le prix
goncourt couronne erik orsenna et son
exposition coloniale
le renaudot à rené depestre auteurs
haïtiens de l'anniversaire [ __ ] à 60
ans et ils continuent de faire des
affaires d'or madame monsieur bonsoir
les fabricants multiplient les formes
les couleurs et même les parfums pour en
vanter les mérites il ne recule devant
aucun adjectif flatteur pour
l'utilisateur
les campagnes se multiplient pour en
commander l'emploi en ces temps de
moeurs facile et surtout de sida des
plaisanteries graveleuses au cri
d'alarmé lancé périodiquement par les
experts
les préservatifs se vendent de plus en
plus le marché est porteur et le
ministère de la santé vient de lancer
vous le savez une nouvelle campagne
nationale en faveur de leur utilisation
seulement voilà rien apparemment ne
garantit leur qualité le mensuel 50
millions de consommateurs va publier
dans son prochain numéro
une étude qui est un vrai pavé dans le
latex plus d'un préservatif sur deux
serait de mauvaise qualité
plus d'un sur trois serait inefficace
contre le virus du sida
anna la bouse gonflé jusqu'à la rupture
est tirée mesurée sous toutes les
coutures 40 est une marque de
préservatifs ont passé de durs moments
au laboratoire national d'essai à
l'arrivée 23 marques se sont montrés
défaillante pour des raisons allant de
l'éclatement précoce à l'emballage
défectueux ou encore une porosité
importante amenant à se poser des
questions sur leur efficacité réelle les
bonnes notes sont allés à aulas profil
tex ou du rex en queue on retrouve derby
ça va ou perles 3 mais ce qui est
surtout inquiétant c'est qu'on trouve
encore en vente libre des préservatifs
n'ayant jamais satisfait aux normes
françaises
qu'il semble que ces préservatifs ne
puisse pas laisser passer le virus du
sida
il y a deux raisons pour affirmer cela
la première ce sont des travaux qui ont
été faits spécifiquement pour étudier
l'imperméabilité des préservatifs au
virus du sida dans différents pays et
qui ont montré que toutes les marques
dont certaines sont vendus en france
sont imperméables aux virus et
deuxièmement l'application de la norme
française normes très sévères et qu'il
est ne laisse passer que des toutes
petites molécules
alors que le virus est une grosse
molécule 400 fois plus grosse au moment
où le ministère de la santé s'apprête à
lancer une série de clips pour inciter l
usage du préservatif
il serait peut-être judicieux de rendre
plus dure les tests permettant
d'attribuer les normes nf
ainsi les futurs utilisateurs saurait
que leur santé est parfaitement préservé
d'un conflit à l'autre le climat social
s'alourdit et s'enlise au ptt le
mouvement devient confus la circulation
du courrier a repris mais la grève
continue dans certains centres de tri le
point avec maryse mano aux ptt quelques
centres de tri jusqu'ici épargné par la
grève emboîtent le pas aux chauffeurs
postis de paris après les mesures prises
par paul quilès pour libérer les centres
la plus grande poste de paris rue du
louvre est à nouveau bloqué par une
petite moitié du personnel en grève en
province après orléans amiens le
mouvement gagne maintenant nice
marseille toulon et toulouse
à lyon il n'y avait ni bus ni métro pour
ce 20e jour de grève les négociations
marathon entre direction et
intersyndicale se sont achevées tard la
nuit dernière mais ses deux mains matin
que les employés des transports vote à
bulletin secret sur la poursuite de la
grève
issue incertaine car si les grévistes ne
réclame plus que 500 francs
d'augmentation par mois
la direction elle propose la moitié
seulement à edf tous les syndicats sauf
la cgt viennent de signer le premier
accord salarial 88 89 dont les
entreprises publiques
les agents d'edf auront 2,2 pour cent
d'augmentation en 88 dont une petite
partie rétroactive au 1er janvier et 2,2
pour cent également en 89
mais je crois que c'est un pas en avant
non négligeable faut quand même se
souvenir que depuis plusieurs années
nous étions dans une plastique de perte
de pouvoir d'achat pour la première fois
on revient et donner un coup d'arrêt et
pour nous c'est le point de départ de
retrouver une dynamique de progression
pour demain cet accord qui renoue avec
la politique contractuelle isole la cgt
à la veille de sa journée d'action de
demain
oui le président du cnpf françois
périgot a demandé ce matin au premier
ministre des mesures d'urgence pour
soulager les entreprises qui souffrent
de plus en plus des grèves du secteur
public poste et transports notamment
dans les transports précisément c'est au
tour de la sncf demain d'entrer dans le
mouvement tous les syndicats de
cheminots ont rejeté aujourd'hui le
projet de budget 89 proposé par la
direction générale
attendez vous donc à de sérieuses
perturbations inégale cependant selon
les réseaux et surtout renseignez vous
attend les cheminots n'ont pas le moral
et les raisons sont multiples nicolas
jacobs guichetiers gare de lyon depuis
huit ans 5800 francs par mois
demain didier fontaine militants cfdt
fera grève
avec ses collègues il refuse les
dernières propositions salariales de la
direction comprises entre 2,4 et 3,3
pour cent cette année et 2% 89 alors que
les cheminots évalue à 11 % la perte de
leurs
pouvoir d'achat depuis 83 mais en toile
de fond à ce conflit reviennent la
sécurité les réductions d'effectifs
tout ce qui fait le malaise de la sncf
signe de ce trouble
la direction nous a interdit de filmer
didier fontaine à son poste il a fallu
le rencontrer or de la gare on sent un
ami à l'horizon complètement bouché dans
la mesure où il ya oui effectivement
plus rien bon non seulement déroulement
de carrière en terme de trains il met
aussi un terme d'examens en termes bon
en terme de formation aujourd'hui on a
un bon ensemble de techniques évoluent
et quand dans l'entreprise on n'est
absolument pas associée à ce à dire que
bon les techniques nous tombe dessus on
n'a qu'à s'adapter on n'a aucune
formation qui est prévu on allait
l'information après que la police a mis
en place c'est une entreprise qui
fonctionne de manière complètement
lourdes le climat chez les agents sncf
et plus à la lassitude qu'à une réelle
mobilisation
d'ores et déjà la sncf prévoit un trafic
normal sur les réseaux est nord est et
tgv sur les autres deux trains sur trois
devraient circuler
quant à la banlieue on prévoit un train
sur deux autres secteurs exposés
l'enseignement le ministre de
l'éducation nationale lionel jospin a
entamé aujourd'hui ses négociations avec
les différents syndicats sur la
revalorisation de la condition
enseignante chantal qui perdent le
soutien du ministre est trompeur
lionel jeu se passe c'est que les
négociations seront très difficiles pour
la communale comme pour l'université il
devra s'expliquer cette semaine face à
des partenaires sociaux très déterminé
certitude que deux des négociations
longues et difficiles vont s'engager
le face à face le plus dur c'est sans
nul doute avec le snes qui revendiquent
une augmentation de 25% du salaire des
enseignants
un syndicat qui n'a pas attendu les
négociations pour mener des grèves
tournantes dans tous les lycées
jusqu'à la fin du mois entre le tout
tout de suite et le rien je crois qu'il
ya possibilité de programmer et de
tracer des perspectives
une troisième surprise attendait le
ministre le syndicat des instituteurs
pourtant proche des socialistes entre
deux fronts dans la bagarre ne faut pas
que des gendres les chambres dans au
fond que les orientations soient fixés
et qu'après on lèche les enseignants
travail est un vrai marathon pour lionel
jospin jusqu'à vendredi
le résultat des négociations est attendu
pour la première quinzaine de décembre
en toile de fond aux différents conflits
sociaux la cgt et le parti communiste
qui s'efforcent en chevy d'attiser ou
d'exploiter à leur profit le climat
actuel un climat qui pèse lourd sur le
parti socialiste
des troubles sociaux au malaise
politique le pas est franchi pour
beaucoup de militants socialistes
c'est ce qu'a constaté à la base dans
une section de saint maur plutôt
tendance jospin véronique sainte olive
aujourd'hui c'est quoi
l'indication le premier françois
mitterrand au fond veut voulait veut
casser la droite
j'ai peur que le gouvernement ne
finissent par casser la gauche moi quand
j'entends parler maintenant des
ministres socialistes
certes il est à parier que sur telle
pièce qui en arrive aujourd'hui a menacé
d'envoyer les crs contre des centres dix
ans après il honora leur casquette de
militant socialiste et il le dit sans
tourner autour du cou ces socialistes de
la base ne comprennent plus avec la
réélection de françois mitterrand il
attendait une gauche triomphante
ils ont turc art et l'ouverture espérait
des mesures sociales mais leurs
revendications se multiplient dans le
vide et leurs camarades sont dans la rue
ça continue comme ça c'est moi facilité
sur paris qu'en argentine avec 26 ou
bien parce que premièrement je suis
obligé d'être solidaire des grévistes
mais je d'oublier ça je suis sûr
libération domanick jeudi dans la
librairie
on est vraiment dépassé parce que on
lance la gamme des notes la grève
administrative
les grèves tournantes qu'est ce qu'on
fait là dedans milieu on va descendre
dans la rue
moi je suis je flat jaulin aujourd'hui
les militants de base désemparés et
désorientés par l'action du gouvernement
rocard se retourne vers le parti plus
question de blanc seing l'heure est à la
vigilance
ça veut dire que le parti jali sera plus
un parti godillot comme entre 81 et 86
ça veut dire que les socialistes diront
tout haut ce que pense le travail en bas
à gauche la 110 cool mais les
socialistes qui ne veulent pas jouer les
incendiaires débattent pour trouver une
nouvelle stratégie pour eux elle passe
tout simplement par la reconnaissance
d'un électorat acquis il faut donner du
grain à moudre ce qui manque lassé des
signes des signes envers envers les gens
qui bougent qui s'inquiètent pour leur
montrer que bones gouvernement et a été
élu par eux pour eux et les valeurs
valeurs donné satisfaction parce que
c'est fondamentalement ce pourquoi elle
était élue on défend gouvernement mais
entre nous effectivement on peut
critiquer le gouvernement
et vous les faites quand même confiance
aujourd'hui contre la droite ont
clairement contre la droite oui et c'est
vrai car si les militants socialistes de
sa mort grogne se fâche et critique
aucun d'entre eux à ce jour n'a encore
déchiré sa carte du parti
deux socialistes pour un fauteuil celui
de la mairie de marseille tractations et
rumeurs vont bon train depuis la
désignation hier de michel pezet
candidat officiel du parti socialiste
aux prochaines municipales et la volonté
de maintien du maire actuel robert
vigouroux
la campagne est déjà commencée sur place
roland seeker un tiers de peser un tiers
de vigouroux un tiers de bodin un tiers
de front national et de parti communiste
comme dans la fable le pastis
marseillais est une alchimie complexe et
de fait la décision du maire de
marseille de maintenir sa candidature a
plongé les socialistes marseillais dans
l'embarras
deux prétendants pour un seul fauteuil
chez trop pourtant michel pezet le
candidat régulièrement investi préfère
ne pas jeter d'huile sur le feu
nous sommes face à un georges et ce
danger c'est la droite d'une droite à
marseille qui est allié au front
national il faut tant qu'il y ait
l'ensemble d'abord l'ensemble des
socialistes
l'ensemble de la gauche et au delà
michel pezet qui voudrait rassembler
pourtant les deux états-majors pense
pour l'instant plus à la constitution de
leur liste qu'un éventuel accord
une division qui pourrait faire les
affaires de jean claude gaudin le
candidat de l'udf enfonce le clou
ce qui est navrant ce sont pas les
rivalités les ambitions entre les
personnes c'est que cette ville depuis
trois ans n'a plus été dirigées que
cette ville n'est pas en état de marche
déjà trois candidats en lice et pourtant
les grandes manoeuvres ne font que
commencer
bernard tapie aurait été pressenti pour
figurer sur la liste de robert vigouroux
la bataille de la mairie de marseille
s'annonce chaud simplification du
processus encouragements accrue aux
ménages à revenus modestes qui veulent
acheter leur logement
c'est le sens du rapport établi par jean
michel bloch lainé à la demande du
gouvernement et dont le ministre du
logement et ford ont maintenant décidé
l'application jean pellieux l'accession
sociale actuellement repose sur un prêt
le pape et une aide personnelle au
logement apl
le pape à taux progressifs n'a plus de
sens avec la désinflation et la paix
elle coûte de plus en plus cher au
budget on remplacera donc pas pap elle
par une forte prime d'environ 80 mille
francs complété par une aide personnelle
le tout 120 mille francs réservé aux
ménages modestes
toutes les banques pourront accorder les
prêts qui compléteront cette prime
aujourd'hui les papes sont délivrés par
des établissements spécialisés crédit
foncier et crédits immobiliers les
banques seront mises en concurrence afin
d'obtenir après un taux d'environ 10%
autre originalité la prime pourra servir
à acheter un logement ancien l'ancien
étant 25 à 30% moins cher que le neuf
le gouvernement espère rendre ainsi
l'accession possible aux moins fortunés
pour éviter que des marchands sans
scrupules ne vendent des taudis une
expertise sera sans doute obligatoires
enfin on demandera à l'acquéreur un
apport personnel avec une épargne
préalable obtenu après deux à trois ans
d'efforts
un effort qui permettra aux ménages de
tester leur capacité de rembourser
ensuite la même somme pendant 15 à 20
ans c'est un accident de la route
particulièrement affreux qui a frappé
hier soir un père et ses petites filles
sur l'autoroute de l'est près de quincy
en seine et marne
un accident qui a aussi bouleversé la
vie d'une jeune femme qui s'est
présentée tout à l'heure à la
gendarmerie de melun et laurette écrasé
sans s'en rendre compte et avant
beaucoup d'autres automobilistes
la petite guerre
qui était parti chercher secours alors
que son père se mourait au bord de
l'autoroute après un dérapage fatal
michel mompontet claude crespo au bord
de l'autoroute a4 gaël 12 ans amélie six
ans et leur petite soeur marion il fait
nuit
leur père le docteur gombert vient
d'avoir un accident sa voiture s'est
retournée
il est sans connaissance ses trois
enfants ont été l éjecter indemne de ce
véhicule
gaël l'aîné par alors chercher du
secours elle croit que les
automobilistes circulant sur l'autoroute
vont s'arrêter et sauver son père elle
croit que ces crises et ses signes vont
suffire
une voiture la fauche sur le bas côté
elle est tuée sur le coup
la jeune femme au volant qui viennent
l'accroché s'enfuit elle ne s'est rendu
aujourd'hui à la police traumatisée mais
le drame n'est pas clos plus d'une
vingtaine de voitures vont alors roulé
sur le corps de gaël aucune ne va
s'arrêter
aucune non plus ne verra deux petites
filles panique et demandant du secours
au bord de cette autoroute la première
voiture ne s'arrêtera que 20 minutes
plus tard le délit de fuite n'est pas
chose courante sur les routes françaises
en ce qui concerne les accidents mortels
à peine un sur cent précise la sécurité
routière en revanche pour les accidents
corporels
le délit de fuite est d'une banalité
dramatique
c'était hier soir sur l'autoroute de
l'est près d'alger
le conseil national palestinien se
prépare un geste sans précédent dans
l'interminable et douloureux conflit du
proche orient dans les heures qui
viennent la centrale devrait voté à une
large majorité un projet de déclaration
politique imposée par yasser arafat qui
définit ainsi une nouvelle stratégie à
destination de jérusalem bien sûr mais
aussi de washington alger au brier de
l'air que les palestiniens semble cette
fois décidée à franchir après quarante
années de combat et de haine
les délégués du conseil national
palestinien mon sens aucun doute
accepter dans leur communiqué final la
résolution 242 des nations unies qui
stipule clairement la reconnaissance de
l'état d'israël dans des frontières
sûres mais également le retrait
israélien de territoires occupés y
compris la ville de jérusalem un texte
voté par l'onu au lendemain de la guerre
de 67 qui pourrait être la base d'une
éventuelle conférence internationale sur
la paix au proche orient
le nationaliste georges habache a donc
accepté après des nuits entières d'âpres
discussions ce qui lui semblait
impossible d'envisager avant l'intifada
il y a quelques mois encore il ne
devrait néanmoins pas voter le texte du
cnp se contentant de s'abstenir pour ne
pas troubler la volonté d'unité affichée
par la centrale palestinienne
en revanche pour la partie minorité sa
pâte faite à voter contre les
résolutions proposées
mais ce n'est que demain en séance
extraordinaire que yasser arafat
donnerait à ce cnp son impact
psychologique et médiatique en annonçant
la déclaration d'indépendance de l'état
de palestine
ce serait en tout cas la première fois
que le vote à la majorité se
substituerait au scrutin à l'unanimité
traditionnel mais souvent démenties sur
le terrain le cnp se transformant ainsi
en un réel parlement aux règles
apparemment démocratique
oui et le son en provenance d'alger et
bien mauvais vous en êtes rendu compte
le point essentiel donc l'ol paie va
accepter la fameuse résolution 242 que
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
a voté il ya 21 ans et qui entraîne
implicitement la reconnaissance de
l'état d'israël jacques merlino 29
novembre 1947 l'assemblée générale de
l'onu votent le partage de la palestine
en un état juif et un état palestinien
les frontières définies alors seront de
courte durée un premier conflit entre
israéliens et arabes
les bouleverse l'état d'israël ne tarde
pas à s'agrandir juin 1967
nouveau conflit entre israël et ses
voisins l'état hébreu occupe le sinaï
la bande de gaza la cisjordanie
et une partie du goal en cinq mois plus
tard le conseil de sécurité des nations
unies adopte la résolution 242
résolution qui comporte deux points
essentiels le premier prévoyait le
retrait des forces armées israéliennes
des territoires occupés pendant le
conflit de juin 1967
depuis vingt ans ce point fait l'objet
d'une polémique car si la version
française est clair la version anglaise
laisse subsister un doute
elle ne précise pas si israël doit se
retirer de tous les territoires occupés
ou seulement de certains
le second point stipulait que chaque
état de la région voyait sa souveraineté
reconnue et que son intégralité et son
indépendance était assurée point
important puisqu'il entraîne la
reconnaissance d'israël par les
palestiniens
dès lors que ceux-ci adoptent cette
résolution il sape shamir qui a été
officiellement chargé aujourd'hui par le
président d'israël de former un prochain
gouvernement de coalition avec les deux
principaux partis religieux et d'extrême
droite et samir dos a déjà pris les
devants
tandis que l'armée israélienne s'est
déployée en force à gaza et en
cisjordanie pour prévenir tout
embrasement palestiniens le premier
ministre israélien disait ce matin son
scepticisme vis-à-vis du tournant
palestinien n'est pas tactique 10 et ils
seront pourtant yasser arafat est en
train de réussir une opération
diplomatique qui risque de compliquer
encore la tâche du prochain gouvernement
israélien car ses rangs oui c'est une
situation finalement assez renversante
et finalement très compliqué
d'un côté illzach shamir donc ne cesse
d'affirmer qu'il ne reconnaîtra jamais
l'ol paie et qui lui se discutera jamais
avec elle prenant ainsi le risque de
devenir l'homme du refus alors que
jusqu'à leur fuite et arabes
et puis en face enfin je veux dire à
alger eh bien on aille assez rare à
fatick le coût de ce projet dans le
cadre de la légalité internationale
c'est à dire des résolutions des
nations-unies en ou non de parler avec
ajoutent-ils une condition c'est que
c'est cette légalité internationale soit
applicable aux deux parties c'est à dire
en clair et dire aux palestiniens et à
israël ce qui est donc que vous le
disait une reconnaissance implicite
alors c'est une opération effectivement
tactique peut-être et arafat doute été
l'homme du refus le chef du parti du
refus devient tout d'un coup l'homme
d'un certain dialogue possible et ça
c'est important
ce qui est
et ce qu'est pour lui c'est que si ces
résolutions qu'il va réussir à faire
adopter par le conseil national ne sont
pas mises en pratique sur le terrain
tous ceux qui soutiennent aujourd'hui
vont se retourner contre lui et c'est
sans doute là dessus que quand ils sachs
jamie alors la paix de tous nos vous
allez me dire eh bien elle est reproché
une fois de plus dans ces commissions a
plus loin en tout cas déjà le colonel
kadhafi s'indigne à washington comme à
moscou on attend avant de réagir la
formulation exacte du texte qui devrait
donc être voté cet lui alger remous
autour du dollar et manoeuvres en
coulisses le secrétaire américain au
trésor a démenti tout à l'heure
l'intention de son gouvernement de
pousser à la baisse du dollar la devise
américaine est passé ce matin à paris en
dessous des 6 francs et les suppléants
des ministres des finances des sept
grands pays industrialisés pourraient se
réunir incessamment et discrètement à
paris cinq jours après l'élection
présidentielle la presse américaine a
trouvé matière à un nouveau duel un duel
de dames
ce n'est plus bouche loukakis mais
barbra nancy la future première dame des
etats-unis 43 ans de mariage et 17
déménagement impose déjà un style qui
n'est pas tout à fait celui de madame
reggane comme l'observent tolno
le soir de la victoire george bush
heureux aux côtés de sa femme barbara
mais pendant la campagne électorale les
pousses du vice président aura été
stoïque devant la méchanceté des
électeurs qui n'ont pas toujours été
très élégant
barbara se plaint aujourd'hui on m'a
trouvé trop vieille certains m'ont
conseillé de me faire teindre les
cheveux
d'autres m'ont pris pour la mère de
george mais la mère de george bush la
voix si nous l'avions rencontré en mai
dernier à miami
barbara bush et mère de cinq enfants et
grand-mère de dix petits enfants elle a
déjà annoncé que ceux ci viendrait jouer
sur la pelouse de la maison blanche
il faut remonter à john kennedy pour
retrouver la présence d'enfants à la
résidence des présidents américains
madame bouche veut avoir une présence
vigilante mais discret auprès de son
mari
les américains ont en général pour la
première dame des etats unis une
tendresse toute particulière
ils ont déjà pardonné à nancy reagan son
autoritarisme et surtout d'avoir
consulté les astrologues pour déterminer
l'emploi du temps exact de son mari noob
le plaidoyer aujourd'hui en faveur de
mikhaïl gorbatchev à bologne
alexandre do check a lancé avery brandt
appel à ce qu'il a appelé la grande
maison européenne pour qu'elle soutienne
la tentative dorval chef et à washington
rencontre symbolique aujourd'hui à la
maison blanche le président reagan a
reçu andré sakharov emmanuel vanille
soutien critique à la politique de
mereiles gorbatchev c'est ce que
l'ancien dissident soviétique est venu
expliquer au président américain
andreï sakharov est de fait un partisan
inconditionnel de la pérestroïka la
restructuration du système soviétique
engagée par le kremlin son échec dit-il
je cite qu'on dirait moscou a considéré
l'expansion territoriale comme une
nécessité politique ce qui ferait de
l'union soviétique un pays très
dangereux pour l'équilibré mondial
fin de citation
les derniers boulons sont serrés burhan
la tempête de neige en russe est à
nouveau prête à décoller il y a trois
semaines le compte à rebours avait été
interrompu 51 secondes avant l'allumage
tous les problèmes ne semble avoir été
réglé cette fois la première navette
spatiale soviétique devraient décoller à
4 heures du matin heure française vol
automatique sans équipage un rapide
aller retour dans l'espace deux tours de
terre et bourhane reviendra se poser non
loin de son site de lancement
élections municipales demain au brésil
peu de discours politiques mais des
arguments chocs dans le nord du pays on
recrute des tueurs à gages trois
candidats assassiné à rio campagne
beaucoup plus chaleureuse les tracts des
candidats ont cette allure des arguments
de poids
de quoi convaincre les abstentionnistes
les plus farouches l'épopée du
caoutchouc le vagabondage tout en humour
et en sensibilité au cours de 75 ans
d'histoire de france ce sont le thème et
le style d'erik orsenna prix goncourt 88
6 tours de scrutin et une voix de mieux
sur bernard henri lévy sylvie marion a
succombé au charme de l'auteur erik
orsenna prix goncourt 1988 et le plus
gai des romanciers il rit tout le temps
il adore faire des phares il était au
comble du bonheur à l'annoncé de son
prix moi je crois que ma mère me regarde
en ce moment et je l'embrassais là son
roman l'exposition coloniale est aussi
un roman très jubilatoire
c'est une histoire de 1883 à 1954 il ya
une grand-mère qui rêvent d'en pire ya
un père qui est un assez grand cas
valeurs ayant un fils qui va très vite
tombé amoureux de deux soeurs et puis il
se promène à travers le siècle promène à
travers l'angleterre le brésil
l'indochine et puis ils sont des gens
qui sont un peu amoureux tout le temps
et les très gourmand de tas de choses de
dames bien sûr mais aussi de bonne
cuisine de voyage de forêt de course
automobile de bicyclettes et voilà donc
j'ai essayé de raconter tout ce que
j'aimais bien
erik orsenna et est en bonne compagnie
avec rené depestre prix renaudot qui
décrit ainsi son propre livre
je croise athènes éloge du réel
merveilleux féminin sur le réel
merveilleux femina orsenna et depestre
sont bien d'accord le goncourt et le
renaudot 88 un très bon cru de très
belles histoires qui reflète la joie de
vivre de leurs auteurs le titre du prix
renaudot donc de rené depestre adriana
dans tous mes rêves
publié chez gallimard et puis cette
innovation applaudir une heure après
l'attribution du goncourt
l'exposition coloniale d'erik orsenna et
est disponible en braille informatique
grâce à la fondation bull qui a inventé
un système d'ordinateurs en relief pour
les aveugles prochain prix pour les
auteurs malheureux jeudi le grand prix
de l'académie française
il fête ses 60 ans sans une ride
mickey qui n'a pas fini d'enchanter les
grands et les petits enfants
mickey bien né en novembre 1928 il a un
peu changé depuis mais il continue de
régner sans partage dans le monde entier
et de faire des affaires en or
georges bigot new york 18 novembre 1928
en noir et blanc muet crève l'écran
depuis l'espiègle sourisseau a donné 188
film
sourisseau vous avez dit souris mickey
ne demain souris qu'après de longs mois
d'hésitations son père olle disney pour
les temps faire d'abord un moustique
puis un lapin enfin un chat curieuse
filiation c'est à félix le chat de la
souris doit beaucoup dans les années 20
la mode était à ce félin malin en 60 ans
le vaillants rongeurs a considérablement
agrandi son fromage et s'est imposé
comme un redoutable businessman 2400
société en acheter deux parlements des
contrats de licences le chiffre
d'affaires annuel réalisé à partir de
mickey représente 5 millions de francs a
pris peur et mickey bon courage pour la
tournée l'exposition qui racontera son
histoire dans 80 villes de france et
touchera quelques six millions de
visiteurs
ap gosse des encore un autre
anniversaire c'était aujourd'hui dans
l'humour toujours celui du prince
charles à birmingham aujourd'hui au
milieu des jeunes déshérités
quand ils s'occupent il arborait en
boutonnière un badge comme on dit une
formule que personne ne revenir à la vie
commence à 40 ans sans transition les
pronostics de pierre de bresse pour le
tiercé demain à saint cloud vous allez
voilà les voici sur votre écran le 2 le
12 le 7 le 1 le 3 le 17 le 9 et le 14
vers 23 heures tout à l'heure henri
sannier vous présentera la dernière
édition de ce journal tout de suite
après les chiffres et les lettres
demain 6h45 comme tous les matins roger
zabel invité des 4 vérités pierre
guillen le vice président du cnpf dans
un instant laurent cabrol très bonne
soirée sur antenne 2 admirateurs